[Music]
[Music]
to Earth's residence which was situated
here was said to be more splendid than
his houses in other places it was made
of polished boards and surrounded with
wooden enclosures designed not so much
for protection as for appearances sake
the house of the chieftain on agusi as'
was second only to the kings in
splendour and was also encircled with a
wooden enclosure but it was not adorned
with towers like that of the king not
far from the enclosure was a large bath
built biology seus who was the second in
power among the city ins the stones for
this bath had been brought from Pannonia
for the barbarians in this district had
no stones or trees but used imported
material the next day I entered the
enclosure of atilla's palace bearing
gifts to his wife whose name was cracker
she had three sons of whom the eldest
governed the akka Tier II and the other
nations who dwell in Pontic Sevilla
within enclosures were numerous
buildings some of carved boards
beautifully fitted together others of
straight panned beams without carving
fastened on round wooden blocks which
rose to a moderate height from the
ground atilla's wife lived here and
having been admitted by the barbarians
at the door I found her reclining on a
soft couch the floor of the room was
covered with woolen mats for walking on
a number of servants stood round her and
made sitting on the floor in front of
her embroidered with colours linen
cloths intended to be placed over the
Scythian dress for ornament having
approached saluted her and presented the
gifts I went out and walked to the other
houses where Attila was and waited for
unagi's seus who as I knew was with
Attila
so number of people advancing and a
great commotion and noise nutella's
egress being expected and he came forth
from the house with a dignified strut
looking round on this side and that he
was accompanied by our geese yes and
stood in front of the house and many
persons who had lawsuits with one
another came up and received his
judgement then he returned into the
house and received ambassador's of
barbarous people's we're ovate it to a
banquet with a teller at three o'clock
when the hour arrived we went to the
palace along with the embassy from the
Western Roman's and stood on the
threshold of the hall in the presence of
Attila
[Music]
the cupbearers gave us a cuff according
to the national custom that we might
pray before we sat down having tasted
the cup we proceeded to take our seats
all the chairs being arranged along the
wall of the room on either side attila
sat in the middle on a couch a second
couch was set behind him and from its
steps led up to his bed which was
covered with the linen sheets and
wrought coverlets
for ornament such as Greeks and Romans
used to deck bridal beds the places on
the right of Attila were held chief in
honor those on the left where we sat
were only second first the king and his
guests pledged one another with the wine
when this ceremony was over the cup
bearers retired and tables large enough
for three or four even more to sit at
were placed next to the table of a
tiller so that each could take of the
food on the dishes without leaving his
seat the attendant of a tiller first
entered with a dish full of meat and
behind him came the other attendants
with bread and viens which they lay on
the tables a luxurious meal served on
silver plate had been made ready for us
and the barbarian guests but Attila
ain't nothing but meat on a wooden
trencher in everything else too he
showed himself temperate his cup was of
wood while to the guests were given
goblets of gold and silver his dress too
was quite simple affecting only to be
clean the sword he carried at his side
the latch 'it's of his civilian shoes
the bridle of his horse were not adorned
like those of the other Citians with
gold or gems or anything costly when the
viens of the first course had been
consumed we all stood up did not resumed
our seats until each one in the order
before observed drank to the health of
Attila in the goblet of wine presented
to him we then sat down
and the second dish was placed on each
table with eatables of another kind
after this course the same ceremony was
observed as after the first when evening
fell torches were lit and two barbarians
coming forward in front of Attila sang
songs they had composed celebrating his
victories and diesel valor in war
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]